the first headline I see right here as
citigroup's capital plan was approved by
the Federal Reserve so this is
vindication for Michael Corbitt CEO of
Citigroup who a lot of people were
wondering whether he would lose his job
if Citigroup did not pass this part of
the stress test but now that it has
gotten the ok analysts are looking for a
10-cent quarterly dividend up from the
current token 1 cent Bank of America
gets a conditional approval that means
that it still needs to shore up its
internal processes and resubmit its
capital plan but assuming that goes okay
it'll be able to return capital to
shareholders Deutsche Bank and Santander
the US units of this German make and the
Spanish bank have failed this part of
the Federal Reserve's stress tests
JPMorgan Goldman Sachs and Morgan
Stanley have all passed but with an
asterisk because they had to first
revise their proposals in order for them
to get the passing mark this is a Fed
5th year that the Federal Reserve has
scrutinized banks as capital planning
processes and we know that the Fed looks
at both quantitative and qualitative
factors quantitative are the projected
capital ratios under a worst and worst
case scenario hypothetical scenarios
qualitative is less numbers based and
more based on the perceived strength of
a company's financial and capital
planning processes and this is what
we're looking at when we determine or
when the Fed determines whether these
banks should be able to return cash to
shareholders through dividends and
through buybacks